so just reflect a minute you know to get
to the moon and back again required real
kind of imagination a goal to be set but
fundamentally dynamic and in
economy-wide interactions between
different actors to fuel investment in
innovation for a common purpose so there
was the challenge the broad challenge
was at the time the space race and
Sputnik the moon shot was very specific
but it required many different sectors
to innovate not just Aeronautics there
was nutrition and materials there was
about 12 different sectors and then what
government did was really transform its
instruments like procurement and price
schemes and grants to fuel that
bottom-up experimentation so over 300
projects in order to get to the moon of
which many failed so again that kind of
risk-taking really shared across many
different actors but also you know
bottom-up experimentation also in
business in order to reach a common goal
[Music]